hey there i'm lindsey and i'm here with
Ryan Bernard who is a game director on
the awesome game the division how long
did it take you to our develop this game
well development still ongoing we're
coming out in 2015 no that's cool ah and
we've been working on it for about the
past couple years now awesome awesome oh
look we saw the press conference and
that trailer was just perfect some of
the I noticed some of the technology you
guys are using like steam particles and
stuff like that lighting through it just
looks incredible can you expand on that
well I do mean the trailer at Microsoft
or the trailer at Ubisoft trailer at
Ubisoft so the extended story story
trailer the one that's getting all the
hype and making people weep well that's
actually a CGI trailer then we made in
in partnership with blur so we're very
involved creatively with them on kind of
what we needed to see we want to set up
kind of a human story which is the start
you see how the virus affects one family
and then how that the follow of New York
starts to affect everyone so we're
really pleased with it all we we saw
some gameplay on the show floor I really
loved the use of gadgets and stuff like
that like the grenade I'm like being
able to change it can you expand on that
sure so worried we like to say a word
RPG first at our course so we're a third
person RPG and so the synergy between
the weapon that you use and the gadgets
you were talking about the skills for
the player is really important so you're
going to want to find the skills that
match up with the kind of play style
that you like if you're an aggressive
player that uses a shotgun up close
you're going to want to match that with
skills that complement that play style
excellent odd yeah I really love the
flexibility of that I I found it so cool
and the cover system it's just really
cool yes it thanks is something by Ryan
and talking about the division enjoy
your stay at e3
you